I am at the three-point line that's a
shot as a coach you live with if he's on
your team
where's Angus against Larry Nance gets
in the paint so that's where the height
difference just makes it impossible to
stop fall off the mark from free wear
this year he's shooting just 25 percent
from downtown porzingis ketchup shoot
there's Jack coming off the season I 19
points on Sunday night walls 3 it's her
kristaps porzingis
with eight points in about a minute this
cost this year frustrated not starting
frustrated at times not playing but he's
statement plannin porzingis with the
finish
ten points before Zynga's the latina
wife Lanza ball they wanted to be more
aggressive offensively as porzingis
easily shoots over ball it's trying to
push for the lakers have done a good job
in transition porzingis way outside hits
a three his second three-pointer they've
done a terrific job so far
leave open corner three in and out
[Music]
that's have regained the lead
while silver tries against Lopez
defensive well fakes leans in one-handed
shot is covered how about that four guys
seven three in transition ball couldn't
quite get it or isn't yes able to do so
Jack the porzingis sets the three but
today he's three for three from downtown
i'll Zynga's kicks it out to Jarrett
Jack back back out for Zynga's shoots a
three
[Applause]
he's 4 for 4 from downtown and that was
26 10 three-pointer for the Lakers jack
- porzingis steps back
[Applause]
twenty-nine
[Applause]
courtney lee to porzingis porzingis on
the drive
pull-up jumper x-ray 31-foot porzingis
swish with Kuzma on him
so rookie drives back up to pros Inga's
one dribble falling away
[Applause]
back up five minute remaining porzingis
spins against Guzman down a lane running
[Applause]